we have the latest inflation numbers
these numbers have been much anticipated
there were
rumors flying around that year-over-year
inflation once march 2022 numbers were
added in would get into the double
digits over 10
and that didn't happen and we're going
to talk about expectations we're also
going to talk about what the number
means but first
we all know if we participate in the
american economy meaning if you buy
groceries
go out to eat
own a vehicle a gas vehicle pay
utilities i mean everything is more
expensive my electrical bill is up my
grocery bill is up people who have gas
vehicles see that gas is more expensive
we know intuitively because of our
experience in the economy that prices
are up and the question is how much and
in what sectors
and
we now have
that information and inflation has
indeed increased by the most
since 1981
and the consumer price index is up 8.5
percent now there are people confused
about what this means but the reporting
is also confusing when we talk about an
eight point five percent price increase
we don't mean
that in march prices went up eight four
eight point five percent however a lot
of the reporting makes it seem that way
i mean look at this yahoo finance
headline which says inflation rises by
the most since 1981 as the consumer
price index jumps 8.5 percent in march
i understand why some people are
confused but so that you know
this number means that in the year
ending march 2022
the consumer price index is up 8.5
the previous number was february to
february the new number eight point five
percent is march to march prices didn't
go up eight point five percent in march
they went up eight point five percent in
the year ending march now it's on on the
one hand why am i talking about this so
much on the other hand if you don't
understand that you don't have any idea
what's going on and there's people all
over twitter and all over my feed saying
can can you believe it
prices are up almost 10 percent in one
month no no they're not these are high
numbers these are the highest inflation
numbers since 1981 for a one year period
but unless we all are on the same page
about what this means
we're really not going to get anywhere
and the reporting doesn't doesn't make
it particularly more clear now you look
in more detail
um at the numbers and you see that there
are um a number of different areas that
that are sort of leading this some of
the biggest contributors to the increase
were food we know that we know groceries
are are up we joke a lot about mango
prices but but grocery prices are up
shelter
uh
rents and and home property uh
properties uh real estate and gasoline
and the index tracking gas prices surged
up uh 18.3
month on month in march
comprising more than half of the total
monthly increase so
half of the increase in prices in march
was gasoline alone
and um in february gasoline had a 6.6
monthly increase
so
this
this is if you want to have a real
conversation about this you kind of have
to get away from the politics because
there's a lot of this is just joe
biden's fault and of course there's
global inflation gas prices are up
everywhere
the most important aspects of this to me
are are kind of twofold one is the
reaction
why is the stock market up today if
these numbers are so terrible and as of
right now as we're filming the stock
market is up significantly today the
answer that we are taught and we can all
judge whether it makes sense or not
um
is that the market had already priced in
that the numbers could be even worse
there were rumors inflation could be
above ten percent now the actual
economic forecasts were exactly this
they were eight point four percent we
got eight point five percent year over
year but because the market now has the
certainty that it's not going to be
worse than expected the market is doing
well
some people just don't care okay but if
we want to analyze that that would be
one thing to think about
the other aspect of this is there are
lots of people pushing hot takes on
social media that this isn't the real
number that the real number is above 10
and that the metric of the consumer
price index doesn't accurately take that
into account well that's an argument
that you can have at any time
very often when unemployment numbers
come out you will see people come out of
the woodwork and they'll say you know
when in the unemployment system you stop
looking for work you're no longer
considered unemployed so the number is
not accurate
that's true but that's been a reality in
the unemployment system for 40 years
going all the way back to reagan is that
closer to 50 years now
the point is
you can't
cherry pick when you point out the
limitations of a metric to try to make a
point about only the latest numbers
that's dishonest this is the way that
we've measured these things for a long
time uh my prediction and my prediction
is worth as little as everybody else's i
mean i i'm the first to tell you humans
are terrible at making economic
predictions my prediction and this is
just an opinion
is that we're basically at the peak here
of inflation
and that we're going to start seeing a
slow decline in year-over-year inflation
maybe starting next month with this
month's numbers but more likely in the
next two to three months that that's my
prediction what might delay it a little
bit would be gas prices in general tend
to go up over the summer uh more people
driving taking road trips etc and if
that's the case it may push it off even
a little more but my senses
within the next four months
we are going to start to see a decline
that that unless something dramatic
changes should continue
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video